[Musique]
le pass sanitaire a eu des effets
positifs d'une part il a contribué à
protéger les français avec d'autres
mesures et d'autre part il a incité à la
vaccination
aujourd'hui en france la vaccination a
atteint à taux élevés et partout où elle
a atteint un taux élevé nous considérons
que le pass sanitaire ne doit plus être
imposées en revanche dans certains
départements en métropole comme en
outre-mer nous avons des situations où
la vaccination est encore en retard et
où par conséquent les risques de
contamination sont encore trop élevés et
dans ces départements nous sommes prêts
à autoriser le gouvernement à
maintenir pour quelques temps le pass
sanitaires mais ce que nous ne voulons
pas c'est que les gouvernements et les
mains libres pendant une durée trop
longue la démocratie c'est que les
représentants des français le parlement
la représentation nationale vérifie avec
une périodicité aussi courte que
possible que les outils les pouvoirs
exceptionnels qui sont donnés aux
gouvernements sont toujours nécessaires
et sont adaptés à la situation c'est
pourquoi nous ne voulons pas que le
gouvernement puisse faire ce qu'il veut
jusqu'au 31 juillet nous lui donnons
jusqu'au 28 février et s'il faut aller
au delà et bien nous voterons une
nouvelle loi après en avoir délibéré et
si nous le jugeons utile enfin nous ne
voulons pas que les chefs
d'établissements scolaires et des
informations sur le statut vaccinal des
élèves qui leur permettraient de barrer
l'accès en cas de contamination dans le
collège aux élèves non fait sydney des
informations sont couvertes par le
secret médical
et si des élèves ne sont pas vaccinés
mais son cas contactez bien on fera
comme pour les adultes qui sont qu'un
contact c'est-à-dire qu'ils devront
rester chez eux à l'initiative des
parents et à la demande du médecin
[Musique]